hello for now so is calisthenics
functional now I know right away that
this question on its own is going to rub
some people up the wrong way first of
all what is functional well let me start
by defining what I mean by functional in
this case bifunctional I mean something
that has transfer to real world
activities and or Sports and Athletics
so in other words it helps you move
better in your daily life and avoid
injury then it's functional or if it
helps you to perform better in your
given sport or maybe across different
sports then it's functional the good
news is that yes I think calisthenics is
extremely functional in fact if you had
to choose just one radiative training
I'd say that calisthenics would be one
of the most functional you could
possibly pick with that said I also
think that no single form of trading on
its own is enough to create a truly
well-rounded Fitness profile so in this
video I'm going to talk about why I
think calisthenics is so functional so
beneficial I'm going to talk about what
I think is missing and I'm going to talk
about how you can Implement moves and
ideas from other forms of training in
order to create a more comprehensive
training plan
so write out the gate the fact that
you're working out with your own body
weight I think is a massive bonus in
terms of functional performance because
it means your strength is always going
to be relative to your weight that means
you're going to stay light and explosive
means you'll be able to jump higher run
faster pull yourself up climb Etc these
are all examples of using your body in a
dynamic way and calisthenics lends
itself to those things perfectly more to
the point though calisthenics is
fantastic because it builds such
incredible proprioception and teaches
you to strengthen muscles that you might
not even otherwise consider learning any
calisthenics movement is really a whole
journey especially the more advanced
calisthenics movements for example if
you want to learn something like the
planche you can't just brute force your
weight into a plunge trust me I've tried
instead you need to focus on training
your straight arm strength that means
training with the arms locked out
something that you might never have
considered if you've just come from a
bodybuilding or powerlifting background
you need to learn to protract the
scapula you need to learn to tilt your
pelvis and contract the glutes all these
things at the same time you need to be
aware of your whole body doing these
things this is extremely functional
because it's giving you greater
awareness and control over your whole
body this kind of body awareness will
benefit you in every Walk of Life every
physical activity and it's something
that calisthenics does extremely well
and when I say that learning advanced
calisthenics movements is a journey I'm
not kidding it's not just because you
need to learn all this about the body
simply to be able to perform the
movement it's also because it's going to
take a long time you're going to have
setbacks and injuries Lord knows I've
had my fair share you're going to hit
plateaus and need to adapt your training
you're going to need to manage things
like recovery and you're going to try
greasing the groove all of these are
great skills to take into any form of
training and also life skills the amount
of dedication it takes for someone to
learn something like the one-handed
handstand is incredible and I have a
huge amount of respect for those people
if you can work towards something like
that then really you can achieve any
goal
but let's just drop the pretense shall
we you guys aren't interested in
calisthenics or functional training or
even is functional trading you're
interested in this how do I stay looking
So Fresh So youthful I'm joking
obviously being a parent has aged me
about 25 years over the last four years
and that's actually why I'm so grateful
for today's sponsor tiege Hanley so
teach Hanley is a men's skincare brand
and they make the entire process of
maintaining healthy skin for the long
term really really simple subscribe get
a box like this one that contains all of
the different products in the package
that you choose and this time they've
also sent me a hat
it keeps things uncomplicated because
you also get a card with instructions
that shows you precisely how and when to
apply each product and that way there's
no guesswork certainly notice the
difference I think my skin does look and
feel a bit better than it did before and
there's over 5 000 positive customer
reviews that seem to share that opinions
I recommend you start with their level
one system which comes with all the
basics you could need a daily face wash
to get rid of dirt and Grime on your
skin a two times per week exfoliating
scrub to get rid of dead skin cells an
AM moisturizer with SPF 20 and a PM
moisturizer a subscribers will not only
get fantastic skin they also get 20 off
the retail price the ability to pause or
cancel the subscription at any time you
also get exclusive monthly deals free
shipping to the US and low-cost shipping
to most other parts of the world and
because teach Hanley is sponsoring this
video they're also offering a great deal
just click the link in the description
below and you get 30 of your order plus
a free gift don't miss out on this
amazing deal click the link and get
started today now on with the show
it also can't be overstated just how
good calisthenics is for the core when
performed properly so many movements in
calisthenics from Plants to things like
the dragon flag to even push-ups and
plank they've acquired a really stiff
and Powerful core with great rigidity
this transfers excellently to athletic
performance because with a powerful
stable core you're better able to
transfer power to your limbs so far then
calisthenics is looking pretty awesome
so what are these setbacks I was talking
about well first of all like so many
training modalities calisthenics does
lack quite a lot in the transverse plane
the rotational plane that is twisting
the body what you do when you're
throwing a punch pulling a lot of things
or wrestling someone lots of things
involve rotation you can do things like
rotating body weight rows and whilst
those are quite useful they tend to
actually be more to do with the shoulder
rather than rotating the actual core you
can slightly adapt this so that it's
more of a core rotation movement this is
about feeling that mind muscle
connection and rotating there instead of
just pulling yourself in with your arm
but still this is quite a limited amount
for the rotational plane if you want to
get more for a rotation in your
calisthenics training I highly recommend
that you just get a band a resistance
band or a cable pulling machine and you
throw in some Wood Choppers or something
like that alternatively you can use a
kettlebell and do something like Atlas
swings or cross-body kettlebell swings
those sorts of things are going to be
great for adding in that rotational
strength and power
you do also get a little bit of
anti-rotation in the form of something
like wall round push-ups where you're
preventing your body from twisting
towards the ground but you also want to
be actively dynamically rotating the
core if possible
I know many of you are probably thinking
you're probably thinking that one of the
things I'm going to criticize here is
leg strength leg training in
calisthenics but actually I'm going to
take a moment to defend leg training
calisthenics because whilst it's true
that calisthenics isn't ideal for
building massive or aesthetic legs I
actually don't think that should be the
goal if functional performance is what
you're interested in because having
really big bulky legs of course is
detrimental to your performance which is
one of the reasons that calisthenics
athletes don't build them so big and
strong in the first place if you're
interested in running faster like I say
then strength to weight ratio is
actually more important and yes
something like a back squat is fantastic
for improving your jump height but there
are other ways to do this and to improve
your Sprint training without piling a
whole load of weight onto your back so
for example one of the very best things
you can do to improve your running speed
is Nordic curls where you basically
doing hamstring body weight curls what's
the atg split squat is brilliant and
whilst you can do this with dumbbells
it's actually quite effective even
without them
50 squats are brilliant for building
really nice big and powerful quads and
yeah whilst you're not going to build
massively strong legs using calisthenics
I do think you can build very athletic
and performant legs and especially if
you also got that nice focus on Mobility
that does go hand in hand with
calisthenics
I would say that if you want to add a
bit of weight then adding about 30 of
your body weight with dumbbells or
weighted vests something like that the
capital Bell can be fantastic as an
option because this is going to improve
your explosiveness so while I was
editing this video I did just think of
two more things two more points I wanted
to make about calisthenics from a
functional perspective one more positive
and one more negative so to start with
the bad news and calisthenics there's
not much picking stuff up from the
ground there's not much of a hip hinge
even if you do do a hip hinge Movement
Like a body weight deadlift you're not
adding a lot of resistance to that and
so I do recommend some kind of deadlift
maybe a single legged RDL using a
kettlebell something like that something
that has you strengthening your ability
to lift stuff up off the floor but on
the flip side one more positive is that
calisthenics is fantastic for training
your Mobility many of the movements
you're going to want to perform actually
require mobility in order to be able to
achieve such as handstand push-ups they
require shoulder Mobility you can't do
them without it thus you're going to be
naturally incorporating more Mobility
into your training which I think is a
bigger issue for more people than his
max strength so by doing calisthenics
you're going to ensure that your
Mobility is up to scratch alongside your
strength and in many cases that's going
to be Mobility with strength strengthen
those end range positions which is
fantastic but at the same time in some
ways calisthenics's greatest strength
can also be its greatest weakness I'm
talking here about training towards
goals like the planche like a one-armed
handstand even the handstand these are
fantastic as I've said they represent a
fantastic training Journey the amount
you learn about your body just be able
to perform them is incredible but if
you're so singularly focused on one or
two goals they're going to come at the
detriment of other aspects of your
performance and your Fitness
for example one criticism I had of my
training program two functional training
2.0 was that you weren't doing enough
plants training to learn the planche and
it's true you'd only be training
straight arm strength and planche once
or twice a week depending on how you
program the workouts but this was
actually intentional because whilst I'd
love to be able to do the planche I'm
not as interested in doing the plant as
I am in building the properties the
traits that underlie the plants like
that straight arm strength scapular
control with things like the advanced
tuck planche hold or pseudo-punch
push-up multiple times per week that's
very intense on the biceps tendons it's
going to limit the amount of other bicep
training you can do things like chin ups
and that's going to impact on your
biceps size and strength your latch
strength other aspects of your training
and it's even just going to affect the
amount of time you have to do things
like train rotational strength so if you
want a more well-rounded performance
profile I should recommend that you
don't be so laser focused on one or two
goals but Focus instead on being more of
a jack of all trades and except thing
you might not get to the very very peak
in one particular area but it's better
to have lots of skills and lots of areas
not everyone's going to agree with me
here if you're completely focused on
learning those goals and that's great
and like I say I have a huge amount of
respect for people who achieve those
things but if you're interested in
overall well-rounded Fitness and
performance then being so focused on
just one or two goals can be a mistake I
think and the other unfortunate fact of
the matter is that some people just
aren't built to perform plants it's
going to be much harder if you're taller
if you have long heavy legs for example
and whilst I'm not saying it's off the
limits for anybody it can be
disheartening if you're putting in a
whole load of training and you're not
getting there so I think have your eggs
in lots of baskets it's great if you get
those things they're nice to have but
they shouldn't be the sole focus of your
training
now of course this isn't an issue with
calisthenics itself it's more about
programming and the way your program can
make any training modality better or
worse but it is a common issue I see
with calisthenics and it's something to
be aware of if this is going to be your
primary mode of training
let me know what you think in the
comments down below do you think
calisthenics is a functional form of
training do you think you should be
adding additional aspects of other
training modalities on top of it to get
the most from it let me know down below
if you're looking for a training program
that focuses primarily on functional
performance and ties together lots of
different training modalities with a
heavy emphasis on calisthenics actually
then you might enjoy my ebook and
training program super functional
training 2.0 it also comes with over two
hours of instructional training videos
so check it out if you're interested
either way guys thank you so much for
watching this one
bye for now